Which numeric axis shows 47 plus 22?
On the first line we start
with 47, then we add 20 to get to 67.
Finally, add 2 to get to 69.
If you add 20 and then another 2,
you actually add 22.
So that's the right answer.
Let's now see why these options are not true.
Here we add 2 to get to 49,
and then add 2 more and get to 51.
However, we do not add 22.
So we add 2 plus 2, ie we add 4.
To add 22, we need to add 20 and then 2 more.
And with this opportunity here
add 20 and then 2,
but we do not start from 47, but from 74.
That is, the image is 74 plus 22. So I definitely choose
this opportunity here.
Let's take a few more examples.
Which numeric axis shows 93 minus 76?
With all these possibilities we start from 93.
At the first opportunity we take out 7 and then 6.
But to get 76, we have to get 70
and then 6, not just 7.
So I do not like this opportunity.
Here we get 60 and then 7.
But we get a total of 67, not 76.
We have to draw seven tenths.
7 tens and then 6 units.
Here we bring out seven tenths, that is, we take out 70.
And then we get 6 units.
This is definitely the right answer.
Let's look at another example,
just for fun.
Which numeric axis shows 12 plus 87?
They all start at 12.
We'll add 80 and then 7.
8 decades and 7 units.
This right is added to 80,
and then 7, therefore ...
Yes, I choose this opportunity here.